le nazisme né au lendemain de la
Première Guerre mondiale Hitler en
devient le chef de fil et le Parti
national socialiste est bientôt le
principal mouvement de l'extrême droite
allemande il accueille tous ceux qui
nostalgiqu de l'Empire anticommuniste et
antisémite n'ont pas accepté que le
nouveau régime politique la République
de vamar signe le traité de Versailles
qui attribue à l'Allemagne la
responsabilité de la Grande Guerre
[Musique]
au milieu des années 20 l'économie
allemande se redresse la jeune
république Allemande résiste mieux à ses
détracteurs les partis qui acceptent le
régime parlementaire se
[Musique]
renforcent c'est alors que le crash
boursier de 1929 plonge le monde dans le
marasme en 1932 le pays compte 6
millions de chômeurs cette crise
débouche sur une montée du fascisme en
Europe les partis totalitaires vont
exploiter la peur issue de la crise en
1932 aux élections allemandes naz et
communistes obtiennent 53 % des voix
devant la montée des communistes une
partie de l'électorat voit en Hitler un
[Musique]
recours la droite traditionnelle veut
utiliser sa popularité pour instaurer un
régime autoritaire et éradiquer le
communisme le parti d'Hitler devient le
deuxème parti d'Allemagne derrière le
Parti socialiste l'engrenage est
[Musique]
lancé en janvier 1933 adolp Hitler
devient par des voies légal chancelier
du Reich dans la nuit du 30 janvier les
troupes de choc des sa défilent devant
leur fureur maître de l'Allemagne Hitler
peut mettre en œuvre sa révolution
nationale socialiste gobbles déclare
nous allons enfin mettre de l'ordre
porcherie en effet en quelques semaines
se met en place un régime totalitaire
les opposants sont muselés les libertés
publi supprimé les partis les syndicats
diss le 1er juillet 1933 le Parti
national socialiste est proclamé parti
[Applaudissements]
unique
[Musique]
g leses à l'origine garde prétorienne
d'Hitler prend le contrôle de toute la
police allemande et mène la répression
contre les démocrates dirigé par himler
les SS forment une élite sélectionnée
véritable bras armé du nazisme les SS
s'efforce de mettre en place un modèle
d'homme nouveau conforme au critère
biologique du nazisme qui prône
l'inégalité des races au sommet la
pureté de la race arienne et en bas les
autres qui la polluent dont les Juifs
dans minecamp le livre écrit par Hitler
en 1924 il définit les juifs comme des
êtres au sang impur l'antisémitisme est
bien un des fondements majeurs du
nazisme le régime hytlérien veut en
effet créer une société pure débarrasser
des individus jugés débiles et de la
race
inférieure dès leur arrivé au pouvoir
les nazis excluent progressivement les
Juifs de la communauté et tentent de les
faire
[Musique]
fuir
en septembre 1935 les lois de NBER font
des Juifs des citoyens de seconde zone
lors du de la Nuit de Cristal en
novembre 1938 7000 magasins juifs sont
pillés les synagogues
incend
les Juifs sont expropriés pour chasser
arrêtés dans les camps de concentration
ils rejoignent les ennemis du
régime les camps de concentration sont
le prolongement logique de l'idéologie
nazie basé sur l'exclusion dès le 21
mars 1933 de mois après l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'Hitler un camp de
concentration s'ouvre à d'cho près de
Munich un autre suit à orianenburg dans
la bonlieue de
Berlin
puis viendront bukenwald à côté de vmar
1937 Flossenburg en Bavière 1938
Ravensbruck camp de femme près de Berlin
1939 ne game à côté de Hambourg 1940
gros Rosen et mataosen en Autriche
1938 puis le strutov après l'annexion de
l'Alsace l'araignée concentrationnaire
tisse sa toile sur tous les territoires
contrôlés par le Reich
une trentaine de camps auquels sont
rattachés des dizaines de petits camps
de travail les k concentration lager
sont à l'origine destinés à enfermer les
opposants politiques communistes
socialistes démocrates et à les broyer
les mesures disciplinaires sont sadiqu
bestial les SS qui ont la haute main sur
l'administration des camps mêlent au
politique des As sociaux c'est-à-dire
les droits communs les criminels les
Tziganes les handicapés mentaux et
physiques les homosexuels et bien
entendu les Juifs
dans les camps une hiérarchie des
détenus se met en place favorisée par
les SS triangle rouge des politiques
vert pour les droits communs rose pour
les homosexuels jaune pour les
Juifs au fil des ans les internés
plusieurs dizaines de milliers à la
veille de la guerre deviennent un vivier
économique pour le Reich les détenus
forment une main d'œuvre gratuite pour
les industriels et les mines les camps
les plus durs sont édifi à proximité des
carrières comme à matazone où les
esclaves extraient la pierre nécessaire
aux grands travaux
éclairiens après le déclenchement de la
guerre et la mobilisation des ouvriers
allemands dans la verm la dimension
économique du système concentrationnaire
devient plus évidente encore les camps
de concentration ne servent plus
seulement la répression mais fournissent
les bras indispensables aux usines
d'armement cette main d'œuvre
exploitable sans limite Meur sous les
coups meurt d'épuisement MEUR de
maladie
à la fin de 1941 Hitler décide la mise
en route de ce que les nazis appellent
la solution finale à la conférence de
vani en janvier 1942 dans la bonlieue de
Berlin la liquidation des Juifs d'Europe
est planifiée et
rationalisée à côté des camps de la mor
lente les nazis ouvre dans le plus grand
secret des camps de mise à mort
immédiate on passe de la persécution à
la liquidation des camps de
concentration au camp
[Musique]
d'extermination c'est en Pologne que
s'ouvr quatre d'entre eux pour les Juifs
à shelm près de lots on a recours à des
camions à gaz dès décembre 1941 pour
asphyier les juifs polonais belzek
construit en pleine forêt près de Lublin
est mise en service en mars 1942 plus de
500000 Juifs y sont gazés par monoxyde
de
carbone Sobibor où périsent 200000 Juifs
fonctionne à partir du printemps
1942 à partir de juillet 1942 les Juifs
de Varsovie de Lublin sont déportés à
treblina dans une dizaine de chambres à
gaz 750000 juifs sont
[Musique]
assassinés à partir de 1942 himler
décide la construction à côté du camp
d'chwitz 1 d'une véritable usine de mort
à birkenao au début de fermes ont ét
aménagé en chambre à gaz mais devant
l'arrivée massive des convois ces
installations artisanales se révèlent
insuffisantes quatre ensembles chambre à
gaz crématoir sont construits et entrent
en
service la firme hiig farbben fournit le
ziclombé à birkenao sont acheminés les
convois de juifes de France d'Allemagne
des Pays-Bas de Belgique de Grèce et au
cours de l'été 1944 de Hongrie au total
plus d'un million de Juifs d'Europe sont
exterminés à
[Musique]
birkenao au moment même où des photos
aériennes d'Auschwitz parviennent à
l'état-major allié la découverte du
premier camp d'extermination confirme
les pires prévisions l'Armée rouge entre
en effet le 23 juillet 1944 dans le camp
de madanek abandonné par
lesesss une partie du camp a été
détruite mais la chambre à gaz est
intacte des montagnes de chaussures de
lunettes de valises témoigne de
l'extermination de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de juifs
polonais quelques mois plus tard le 23
novembre l'armée américaine entre dans
le camp du strutof en Alsace seul camp
de concentration sur le territoire
français en janvier 1945 l'armée rouge
arrive dans le complexe d'Auschwitz dont
la plupart des déportés ont été évacués
10 jours auparavant dans des conditions
d'épouvantes
3 mois plus tard les Alliés libèrent en
quelques semaines du 4 avril hordrouf au
5 mai matausen les camps de
concentration sur le territoire du 3e
Reich le monde entier découvre la
barbarie
[Musique]
nazie